Tatort Deutschland präsentiert den
dunklen Januar jeden Tag ein neuer
Kriminalfall ein tägliches Tatort
Deutschlands Spezial mein Name ist
skadymo und ich wünsche euch eine
spannende Krimizeit
moin und ich bin Natalie Strauß in den
80ern wird zum ersten Mal in der
deutschen Geschichte ein Fall von
Selbstjustiz auf einer langen zweiten
Bühne verhandelt ganz Deutschland
fiebert mit als Marianne Bachmeier
1983 ihr Urteil erwartet die 33-Jährige
hat drei Jahre zuvor den Mord an ihrer
siebenjährigen Tochter Anna gerecht im
Gerichtssaal hat sie den Mörder ihrer
Tochter erschossen man ist hin und
hergerissen zwischen dem Mitgefühl der
trauernden Mutter und ihrer Straftat wir
brauchen einen ins Leben der Marianne
Bachmeier und keiner kann uns besser in
die Welt des True Crime entführen als du
lieber Marco
vielen lieben Dank und hallo Natalie und
danke auch an all unsere Hörerinnen und
Hörer die uns auch heute wieder
wohlgesonnen sind und dem nächsten
spannenden Fall lauschen werden
Marianne Bachmeier spaltet die Nation
die einen feiern sie nach ihrer Tat wie
eine Heldin und Fühlen Empathie für die
trauernde Mutter andere verurteilen sie
schwer für die Straftat und bezweifeln
das Marianne eine gute Mutter gewesen
sein so oder so erlebt die Frau eine
Form der Anerkennung die sie so bisher
nie erfahren hat
ihr leiblicher Vater ist Alkoholiker und
verlässt die Familie als Marianne 3
Jahre alt ist ihr Stiefvater ist leider
in keinster Weise eine bessere Wahl
ihrer Mutter der Mann verprügelt
Marianne immer wieder verbietet ihr
später aufs Gymnasium zu gehen und als
sie mit 16 Jahren zum ersten Mal
schwanger wird steckt er sie ins Heim
das Kind gibt sie zur Adoption frei
oh mann die junge Frau hat kein Zuhause
und keine Ausbildung ihr fehlt jeglicher
halt auf die erste früher
Schwangerschaft vor die nächste mit 18
bekommen Sie Ihr nächstes Kind auch
dieses gibt sie zur Adoption frei das
sind die teils aus ihrem Privatleben die
als sie später in der Öffentlichkeit
bekannt werden ihr Ansehen als gute
Mutter für viele deutlich schmälern
sollen mit 22 Jahren lernt Mariana dann
Christian bergkalt kennen ein Jahr
später kommt die gemeinsame Tochter Anna
zur Welt die kleine Familie zieht in
Lübeck zusammen und zum ersten Mal
erfährt Marianne das Gefühl von echter
Geborgenheit und Liebe
aber Mirko wie wir alle wissen ist das
leider nur ein kurzer Glücksmoment ne
tja denn da ist sie nun die junge
Familie aber von Luft und Liebe allein
kann man nicht leben
Marianne Bachmeier wird Kneipenwirtin
und arbeitet in ihrem Lokal tipasa oft
bis spät in die Nacht hinein nicht
selten kommt es daher wohl vor dass sie
morgens nur schwer aus dem Bett kommt so
auch am 5 mai 1980 dem Tag der ihr
ganzes Leben auf den Kopf stellen wird
es ist spät geworden nach ihrer Schicht
in der Kneipe ist die 30-Jährige mitten
in der Nacht ins Bett gefallen als sie
am nächsten Morgen aufwacht hat der
Unterricht ihrer sieben Jahre alten
Tochter längst begonnen jetzt ist es
sowieso zu spät Marianne erlaubt Anna
den Schultag zu schwänzen und zum
Spielen rauszugehen vielleicht hat sich
die müde Mutter noch einmal hingelegt
und vertraut darauf dass ihre Tochter in
die Nachbarschaft seiner Freundin geht
sie hat sich Marianne soll ihre kleine
Anna nicht mehr lebendig Wiedersehen oh
Gott oh Gott da geht bei mir direkt das
Kopfkino los ja was ist wenn Marianne
nicht verschlafen hätte was wenn Sie
Anna doch in die Schule geschickt hätte
was wenn sie mit ihr gespielt hätte und
Anna nie aus dem Haus gegangen wäre was
wäre wenn ja diese Fragen müssen
Marianne danach unglaublich verfolgt und
gequält haben wie grausam müssen diese
Schuldgefühle dieser jungen Mutter bloß
gewesen sein die siebenjährige anna ist
im 35-Jährigen Fleischer Klaus Grabowski
in die Hände gefallen
der Mann soll sie bei sich zu Hause
mehrere Stunden festgehalten und
schließlich mit einer Strumpfhose
erdrosselt haben
laut Staatsanwaltschaft hat er die
gefesselte Leiche des Mädchens in einen
Karton gepackt und am Ufer eines Kanals
in einer Mulde abgelegt
später soll er die Leiche in ein Loch
gelegt und mit Erde bedeckt haben er hat
die Tat später am Tag seiner Freundin
gebeichtet die daraufhin zur Polizei
geht noch am selben Abend wird Klaus
Grabowski in einer Gaststätte
festgenommen bei der Vernehmung steht
der Mann die Tötung streitet aber
sexuellen Missbrauch ab Klaus Grabowski
ist für die Polizei kein Unbekannter er
ist bereits wegen sexuellen Missbrauch
von Kindern vor bestraft und saß wegen
pädophiler Neigungen an einem
psychiatrischen Krankenhaus das dürfte
er nur verlassen weil er sich freiwillig
einer Kastration unterzogen hat
Mirko ich hatte ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
auf dem Schirm dass das tatsächlich
durchgeführt wird oder wurde und
anscheinend strafmildern ist zudem hat
es ja nicht mal geholfen nein Natalie
das hat es ganz offensichtlich nicht
bzw hätten seine Triebe dadurch
vielleicht unterdrückt werden können
wäre später nicht eine Hormonbehandlung
beim durchgeführt worden die hat dazu
geführt dass sein sexuelles Empfinden
wieder gesteigert wurde auch hier steht
wieder der Satz was wäre wenn über allem
und gibt uns natürlich keine klare
Antwort
die kleine Anna machen diese
Überlegungen nicht wieder lebendig ihre
Eltern Marianne und Christian reichen
erfolglos eine Strafanzeige gegen den
Urologen ein der die Hormonbehandlung
bei Grabowski durchgeführt und somit
ihrer Meinung nach dessen Gefährlichkeit
wiederhergestellt hat nach dem Tod des
kleinen Mädchens werden die Eltern nicht
nur in tiefe Trauer sondern großen Frust
und Fassungslosigkeit gestürzt es
beginnt mit dem vorbestraften
Sexualstraftäter der in ihrer
unmittelbaren Nähe lebt und ihre Tochter
zur Gefahr wird mit dem Prozess gegen
den Mörder wird es vor allem für
Marianne immer und erträglicher nicht
mal ein Jahr vergeht bis zum ersten
Prozess Tag und bis dahin geht die
Mutter durch die absolute Hölle wie wir
wissen hat sie ihre ersten beiden Kinder
zur Adoption freigegeben die jüngste
Tochter die sie bei sich behalten hat
und bei dir sie vielleicht jetzt alles
richtig machen möchte hat sie nun auf
die grausamste Art und Weise verloren
nach dem Mord gibt sie Annas Körper zur
Obduktion frei später wird Marianne von
einem Psychiater gefragt ob sie den
Mörder ihrer Tochter umgebracht hat weil
sie selbst Schuldgefühle hätte das
verneint sie und schreibt einen wütenden
Brief an den Arzt in ihr Tagebuch wenn
es ein Schuldgefühl gegeben hat dann
dass sie den leblosen Körper ihrer
Tochter nicht vor der Obduktion bewahrt
hat
in einem Interview liest Marianne aus
ihrem Tagebuch vor ich zitiere
ich hätte hingehen müssen in dieses
gruselige Institut hätte die schwingtüre
aufstoßen müssen geradewegs auf den
Aluminiumtisch zu stürzen müssen auf dem
sie ihr eben die Augen mit Pinzetten
aufreißen die für immer geschlossenen
Augen um aufschreiben zu können dass sie
blau waren mein Gott wir nutzt das zu
wissen dass sie blau waren außer mir
welcher Wahrheitsfindung wird hier
gedient ich hätte sie vom Tisch nehmen
müssen ihren folteren entreißen und sie
die mitgebrachte Decke Hüllen denn sie
liegt dort nackt und dann mit ihr
zusammen aus der Schwingtür hinausgehen
müssen ich hätte mit dir sprechen müssen
hier sagen müssen wie die Welt ohne sie
aussieht
dass sie immer noch ein Aussehen hat
diese Welt auch ohne sie wenn auch ganz
anders ich hätte sie fest an mich
drücken müssen um ihr die Angst zu
nehmen vor dem was auf sie zukommt die
Ewigkeit
stattdessen ließ sich sie zerschnibbeln
nennen sie es ruhig Schuldgefühle Herr
Doktor es ist viel mehr es ist eine
nicht wieder gut zu machende Schuld es
zerreißen wirklich das Herz na das muss
man sich einmal vorstellen dein eigenes
Kind wird ermordet vielleicht sogar
sexuelle missbraucht und nach der Tat
kannst du erstmal kein Grab besuchen und
hast das Gefühl dass dein Kind keine
Ruhe finden kann du selbst willst
vielleicht auch einfach nur trauern aber
stattdessen wird alles im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes zerstückelt und auseinander
genommen und dann endlich der Prozess
jetzt soll der Täter für seine Straftat
bestraft werden aber auch hier geht es
weiter und zwar auf Kosten der Toten
Tochter Klaus Grabowski steht im März
1981 vom Landgericht Lübeck eine Aussage
seinerseits steht im Raum
anstatt frei heraus zuzugeben dass er
die kleine Anna entführt womöglich
missbraucht und ermordet hat kommt er
zunächst mit einer Geschichte um die
Ecke die unglaublich ist
er behauptet das Mädchen sei aus freien
Stücken zu ihm gekommen um ihn zu
erpressen eine Mark wollte sie von ihm
haben ansonsten würde sie rumgehen und
erzählen er habe sie angefasst aus Angst
diesmal unschuldig in einer Anstalt zu
kommen habe er sie erwürgt
diese Aussage lässt die Eltern der
kleinen fassungslos auf ihren Stühlen im
Verhandlungssaal zurück
kurz vom dritten Verhandlungstag soll
Marianne Bachmeier auf dem Flur gehört
haben dass Klaus Grabowski erneut eine
Aussage machen möchte außerdem ist der
Gerichtsmediziner Otto privilla geladen
er soll den Obduktionsbericht abgeben
aber so weit soll es nicht kommen
Marianne will auf keinen Fall das über
ihre Tochter noch einmal Lügen
verbreitet werden sie beschließt zu
handeln und so wird der
Gerichtsmediziner pribilla an diesem Tag
keinen Bericht abgeben erst lediglich
vor Ort um den Tod des Angeklagten
festzustellen alles geht verdammt
schnell es ist kurz nach 10 Uhr am
Vormittag gerade haben zwei Wachtmeister
Klaus Grabowski aus der
Untersuchungshaft in den Saal des
Gerichts gebracht der Angeklagte setzt
sich auf seinen Stuhl mit Blick nach
vorne auf den noch leeren Richtertisch
seinen Rücken wendet er dem
Zuschauerraum zu er sieht seine Mörderin
nicht kommen
die dunkelhaarige junge Frau schicke
kleidet im schwarzen Tuchmantel tritt
hervor sie zieht eine Pistole eine
baretta 70 aus ihrer Tasche sie zielt
und schießt 8 Schüsse fallen sechs der
Geschosse mit Kaliber 5,6 mm treffen
Klaus Grabowski in den Rücken der Mann
ist sofort tot Marianne Bachmeier wird
festgenommen und wird über Nacht zur
Berühmtheit
Mitleid mit ihrem Opfer hat wohl keiner
ganz im Gegenteil zunächst wird Marianne
von vielen als Helden gefeiert die
Medien stürzen sich auf die Geschichte
ganz Deutschland schaut zu wird sie als
Mörderin verurteilt es ist wohl eine
Kombination aus dem Mitgefühl für die
Mutter da Wut auf den Täter aber auch
die Attraktivität von Marianne Bachmeier
die im Gesamtbild der Grund sind warum
die meisten Menschen Sympathie für sie
empfinden
Marianne macht sich verdammt gut auf den
Titelbildern der Zeitung eine schlanke
junge Frau mit glatten mittellang
dunkelbraunen Haaren für aussehen kann
sie natürlich nicht aber es ist so
leicht damit so einer gut aussehenden
und natürlich wirken den jungen Frau
mitzufühlen als mit einer möglicherweise
unausgeschlafenen optisch
heruntergekommenen Kneipen wird
sie verkauft die Rechte an ihrer
Lebensgeschichte für rund 250.000 Mark
an den Sternen jetzt geht es nicht mehr
nur um die trauernde Mutter sondern um
den Menschen
Marianne Bachmeier je bekannter Marianne
Wirtz und je mehr die Menschen über sie
erfahren desto weiter gehen die
Meinungen zu ihr auseinander das Bild
der perfekten Mutter die um ihr Kind
trauert wird unter anderem geschmälert
als herauskommt dass sie bereits zwei
Kinder hat zudem behauptet Marianne aus
dem Affekt herausgeschossen zu haben es
sei eine Kurzschlusshandlung gewesen wer
aber bringt eine geladene Waffe mit in
einen Gerichtssaal ohne die Absicht zu
haben diese zu benutzen
wie kann es sein dass eine ungeübte
Schützin so ruhig bleibt und so
treffsicher ist
die beste Freundin von Marianne
Bachmeier sagt später dass Marianne vor
dem Prozessbeginn sehr wohl
Schießübungen gemacht hat heimlich im
Keller und ihrer lauten Kneipe damit die
Nachbarn nichts mitkriegen zehn Monate
sind zwischen dem Tod von Anna Bachmeier
und der Verhandlung gegen Grabowski
vergangen 10 Monate in denen Marianne
Bachmeier durch die Hölle gegangen sein
muss lange genug damit sich Trauer in
Hass verwandeln und ein Racheplan
geschmiedet werden kann
im November 1982 beginnt der Prozess
gegen Marianne die Anklage lautet
zunächst auf Mord am Ende verurteilt sie
das Landgericht im März 1983 allerdings
wegen Totschlags und unerlaubten
Waffenbesitzes zu sechs Jahren Haft
schon zwei Jahre später kommt sie frei
ihre Reststrafe wird zu Bewährung
ausgesetzt
mittlerweile ist Marianne nicht mehr mit
dem Vater von Anna zusammen sondern
heiratet noch im Jahr ihrer Entlassung
einen Lehrer und sieht aus Deutschland
weg nichts hält sie mehr in dem Land in
dem sie so viel gelitten und verloren
hat erst geht sie nach Nigeria später
nach ihrer Scheidung 1990 nach Sizilien
hier fliegt sie sterben dann in einem
Hospiz und schreibt an ihrer
Autobiografie
auch wenn der Wirbel um sie nachgelassen
hat gibt sie bis Mitte der 90er Jahre
immer wieder Interviews und tritt im
Fernsehen auf im September 1995 ist
Marianne Bachmeier in der Talkshow
fliege im Ersten zu Gast hier gesteht
sie dass Sie Klaus Grabowski keineswegs
immer weckt sondern nach reiflicher
Überlegung erschossen habe sie wollte es
nicht zulassen dass dieser weiter
Unwahrheiten über einer verbreitet und
hat es als ihre Pflicht angesehen Recht
über ihn zu sprechen
ich denke und hoffe Mariana hat mit den
Jahren ihren Frieden gefunden und egal
was man von ihr halten mag ein gewisses
Grundverständnis und Mitgefühl wird wo
jeder mit dieser Frau haben ihr Leben
ist gezeichnet von viel Gewalt Ablehnung
Verlust und einer zur Schau Stellung in
der Öffentlichkeit sowohl von der
positiven als auch von der negativen
Seite nur ein Jahr nach dem TV-Auftritt
bei Pflege stirbt Marianne Bachmeier im
Alter von 46 Jahren an
Bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs
mit der Krebsdiagnose ist sie zurück in
ihrer alte Heimat gezogen und ist in
einem Lübecker Krankenhaus gestorben
Marina Bachmeier ist neben dem Grab
ihrer Tochter beigesetzt worden
was für eine Frau egal ob man nur mit
dir sympathisiert oder sie für
berechnend und scharf auf den ganzen
Medien Rummel gehalten hat der Fall
Marianne Bachmeier hat Justizgeschichte
geschrieben ich bin selbst Vater einer
mittlerweile erwachsenen Tochter und ich
mache mir gar nicht vorstellen wie ich
in einer solchen Situation gehandelt
hätte aber bei allem Verständnis für die
Trauer und Wut man darf so ein Verhalten
natürlich nicht rechtfertigen und
legitimieren denn für solche Fälle gibt
es Gesetze und Selbstjustiz kann nur mal
nicht der richtige Weg sein sonst würden
wir in einer Anarchie Leben in der jeder
selbstbestimmen kann was richtig und
falsch ist
aber Natalie wie siehst du diesen Fall
was beschäftigt dich dabei hast du
Verständnis für die Frau oder ist sie
für dich meine Kriminelle
ich finde es total schwierig weil
normalerweise würde ich dir auch total
zustimmen und sagen selbst Justiz ist
keine Lösung und ich würde auch niemals
dazu raten das gut heißen oder
irgendetwas in dieser Richtung aber in
diesem Fall ist Marianne Bachmeier aus
emotionaler Sicht für mich keine
kriminelle sondern einfach nur eine
Mutter ja diese Bestia hat Ihr Kind
brutal aus dem Leben gerissen und
besitzt dann noch die Frechheit derartig
über ihre Tochter zu reden also das
macht mich ja jetzt hier von außen so
viele Jahre später noch unglaublich
wütend ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht vorstellen wie viel Wut und auch
Hilflosigkeit das in der Mutter
hervorgerufen haben muss so oder so ist
es fast schade dass ich dieser Klaus
Grab aus den ich seiner Tat stellen
musste wir werden also nie erfahren was
wirklich an diesem fünften mai 1980
passiert ist das Wissen hat er mit ins
Grab genommen
sicher ist auf jeden Fall dass man aus
dem Fall gelernt hat denn heute sind die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen deutlich höher
heute könnte Marianne Bachmeier nicht
einfach so mit einer geladenen Waffe in
den Saal gehen und einen ungeschützten
Angeklagten erschießen bei allem Hass
bei aller Wut und bei aller Trauer
selbstjustiz ist und bleibt eine
Straftat auch wenn man die Gefühle der
Mutter nachvollziehen kann das war's für
heute wir danken euch fürs zuhören und
freuen uns wenn ihr auch bei der
nächsten Folge wieder dabei seid bei
Tatort Deutschland Spezial euer Mirko
und eure Natalie den spannenden Fall von
Selbstjustiz in Deutschland haben wir
mit dem Archiv der Bild-Zeitung erzählt
so wie Auszügen aus Artikeln der Welt
der Hamburger Morgenpost und in
Deutschland Funk Kalenderblatt außerdem
haben wir uns die spiegelreportage der
Fall Marianne Bachmeier angesehen die
Reportage Marianne Bachmeier selbst
Justiz im Gerichtssaal und das
gesellschaftscrimeformat von Funk der
Fall Redaktion
Stefan Netzeband und Antonia Haie
Produktion serdarinis